most main characters do have
transformations in most hollywood movies
right there's some growth
there are main characters who don't
transform
why is it important for writers to start
their story slowly and take their time
with introducing the characters
that's such a great that's such a great
question because
we need that time to be introduced to
your characters
to create that empathy that we talked
about like
that's where you have the luxury
of having a little bit of time up front
to establish who they are
what they want
why they want it and to allow us to kind
of be introduced to their world
and really get connected to them so that
we're willing to follow them on the
journey
and you know um that takes pages
you know i'm not saying you should spend
like you know 20 pages introducing your
main character you shouldn't if you're
writing a feature for sure you know you
you pretty much do need to kind of get
to that inciting incident or that call
to adventure pretty quickly
but we need but look at wally you know
like that little character we just like
follow him around in his little world
doing his little thing and we learn so
much about him
and we basically fall in love with him
and we will follow that little robot
dude anywhere right and so
but we also get introduced to the world
and the stakes in the world and that
there's nothing really living in the
world you know and so um i think that's
just a really beautiful example of
visually um
starting slow and letting us connect to
our character and his world
and in the queen's gambit i know we we
took some time yes and the back story
wasn't always clear why she was in the
orphanage right and different things are
revealed later and it really keeps you
but why is she reacting this way oh and
then finally you see
the conversation
[Music]
i don't want to give away too much but
yeah just little snippets and it takes
time yeah it takes time and it also
you know as the writer
when you're writing you're starting to
write whether it's your pilot or your
future it's like you know your job is to
create questions not give answers
your your job is to create questions
like why is she like you said why is she
doing that
what's going on here so that the
audience is like
we're just moving closer and closer
because we want to know
why is she acting that way
will she be able to be like a chess
champion will she beat that that guy or
whatever you know it's like all these
questions
that you set up in the story is really
what holds us to the story and so you
know in setting up your character you
don't want to just tell us a bunch of
stuff about the character you know maybe
we see them do something and we go
that's weird why are they doing that
and we keep wondering that until later
we get the answer to that question as as
we start to fully understand kind of who
this person is and why they are the way
they are
you know um so yeah
you're kind of like putting up you're
creating trails you know breadcrumbs and
you're leaving blank spots um and one
thing
one thing to think about too as a writer
which i think is really important is to
create ellipses in your story where
there's gaps where
maybe we you know if you have a section
of your script and it just feels like
here we go every you know then she
drives here and then she gets out then
you know it's like do a time cut like
what's the next scene that moves the
story forward like let us the audience
actively engage with the narrative to
figure it out because the more we're
doing that
the more interested we are in your story
so you know leave gaps ask questions um
and you know um yeah take that time
at the beginning for sure
why is it important for the main
character to have a transformation oh
the main character
okay so
let's be honest most main characters do
have transformations in most
hollywood movies right there's some
growth
um there are main characters who don't
transform
forrest gump
does he change no he just like he just
stays the same through the whole movie
the early james bond movies
james bond doesn't really change he's
just getting the chicks and you know
bringing down the bad guy right so
the thing to remember is
it's not necessarily that your main
character has to transform it's that you
need transformation in your story
because that is actually what's
important so um
so if you have a main character who
doesn't change
and they kind of move through the story
like this what happens is
they change everyone around them
like forrest gump changes everyone
around him but he's still forrest gump
right
you know james bond it's been
interesting to watch him sort of evolve
you know with the daniel craig version
because
9 11 like suddenly james bond became
like this wounded hero where he was
always just the suave martini girls you
know blasting off into space roger moore
he was the one that i grew up with roger
moore
um but it's been interesting to watch
his character evolve you know and become
more of a character that has a tiny bit
more of an emotional
range you know in the in the stories um
but yeah it you know transformation in a
story is a key element and whether it
comes through your main character
or your main character changing um
everyone else it doesn't matter it's
just that transformation is actually the
purpose of a story
it's actually the purpose of the story
because the reason we tell stories is to
actually understand ourselves better
and that insight is a transformation for
us
okay so
however you package your transformation
in your story have at it you know it's
up to you
um but the reason we watch stories is to
be transformed
so if someone were looking to write a
forrest gump type scenario
maybe leave it for a few scripts down
the line because that was very specific
how all that was done and there's many
timelines
yeah that was a very complex script for
sure
um yeah it's easier to write a story
where the main character changes right
because it's just clearer or whatever
but if you really have a character
who doesn't change who kind of takes us
through the story but really the point
of the movie is how this person
changes the world around him or her or
them
then you know for sure write that story
it's just it's just ha think about how
why is that person um why is that person
the catalyst to change all these other
people you know and how can they change
the world around them
you know yeah
great great
yeah i'm not sure with queen's gamut
gambit i would say she she had a shift
she did okay i mean it's not a huge one
right right it's like
did she really change you know
but i felt like she did because i felt
like um
i don't know i'm not an expert on the
queen's gambit
um but i
i like i love what scott frank did
because um
she's she's impenetrable in a way like
she really is impenetrable you know um
and the actress is sort of has that face
that's impenetrable you know
um and at the same time i felt like
i got close to her
i got close to her like the mask was
pierced by the end of the of this of the
show
you know um even though she didn't have
this huge you know transformation like a
lot of main characters do
um but i think she i think she did she
did she did grow and we pierced her mask
we did but she did feel like an engine
driving sort of because even the camera
movement it would follow her up yes you
saw she was driving the shot yes she
brings us into the world and the scenes
um and she is very sort of like
mask-like you know and she doesn't give
a lot of emotion and the character isn't
written that way and um
but i i did feel that i was taken on a
transformative journey for sure
you know and that's that's a that's a
true that's a tribute to scott frank's
abilities as a writer to be able to
coordinate this character
who um
seems at once kind of like opaque
and yet at the same time creates this
feeling of transformation by the end of
that show we're just like
i've had this journey she has taken me
on this journey you know with her um
which was really great